hi guys I'm Olivia Morgan and I'm a
looker seee at Google and today's
session is going to be a technical deep
dive on looker the enterprise bi
solution for Google cloud to start off
with a lightweight agenda we're gonna go
over three key pieces I want to start
with a looker architecture overview then
we'll touch on some of the key points
that I'll be going over in today's
technical deep dive and we'll spend most
of the session on the technical deep
dive itself and so to kick off the
looker architecture overview I wanted to
start with a statement that explains the
BI landscape and how we experience data
and so what this says is how we
experience data is not what it used to
be an effective dashboard is great but
the looker platform opens up a world of
possibilities and by large and in part
the looker platform opens up these
possibilities because of the way that
were architected and because a little
way that we can sit on top of a sequel
database or sequel warehouse so if you
look at this slide at the very bottom
you're gonna see a bunch of different
data sources things like Google Ads
Shopify HubSpot and all of those sources
are pushed into your data warehouse or
your data Lake now looker as a bi
platform sits on top of that database or
data warehouse and it speaks sequel to
that database or data warehouse and in
this case in today's demo we'll be
sitting on top of bigquery and you can
think of looker as a powerful API layer
that brings a lot of different benefits
to the surface for your end-users and
for your technical users one of the key
pieces here is that we have govern
metrics in looker so being that we're
sitting right on top of the database
looker offers a one-stop-shop version
controlled modeling layer or you're
defining your business logic and you're
iterating on that business object in a
vision version controlled way
we also offer best-in-class ap is
so we not only have API endpoints for
data we also have API endpoints for
managing your local instance managing
users
groups or user attributes for those
users we also have powerful API SDKs and
embed SDKs if you're building custom
applications really a core tenant of a
looker and the way that it's architected
is that it's in database so one analogy
I like to use is when you put looker on
top of your database it's like chipping
your car whatever the engine of that car
is in this case we're sitting on top of
bigquery looker is is enhancing all of
the features and functionalities from
that database and will benefit from any
features and functionality that then is
brought upon that database so on top of
those features of course we're version
controlled that allows for additional
security and we are cloud first so
looker does take a multi cloud approach
whether it's GCP or any other cloud from
there we're able to operate in four
different modes if you're thinking of BI
in different ways that you can serve
these analytics to different end-users
the first one on the left is in the red
box modern bi and analytics and that's
your traditional bi data consumption
your reports your dashboards a use case
there might be that you're building a
customer 360 dashboard to view you know
customers across your channels in media
the green box integrated insights is
more along the lines of bringing the
data to where your users already
consumed it so if you have sales folks
that operate in Salesforce don't ask
them to log into another application use
the application to embed those insights
into the tools they already know and
love the yellow box data driven we're
close this essentially automates the
first two parts the idea is that your bi
tool is going to help you uncover those
insights so looker will help you uncover
perhaps customers that are close to
churning based off of a customer helps
to score and then within the looker
application you can use that application
to actually trigger the action you'd
like to take maybe based off of a low
customer health score we're sending
emails to those customers and then the
last one custom applications
a custom application you can spin up in
any way shape or form a large reason why
liquor opens this up in such a powerful
way is because not only we're in
database but we do have a powerful suite
of API is so when you have a version
control and govern layer to pull metrics
from you can create a slew of custom
applications you can use our API as to
render visualizations or data points to
make any sort of custom workflow you can
dream up now for the demo today I wanted
to go over a few key points of the
pieces that I wanted to touch on I
really want to highlight the fact that
this instance is hosted on GCP and we
are going to be sitting on top of
bigquery so what you'll see within the
demo is that we're gonna use Google
Cloud functions and the Search API for
things like product image searches
you'll notice that we have EQ ml at
least within our liquor models for item
sales and stock forecasting we're also
going to use the bigquery weather public
data set so you'll see examples where we
can start to interact with public data
sets to make the analysis richer we're
also leveraging nested tables for things
like faster performance on transaction
analysis in this case and then lastly
we're able to utilize faster and more
efficient queries with bi engine and
Leuchars aggregate awareness so now I'd
like to transition into the technical
deep dive where I can show you looker on
top of GCP and bigquery in the looker
demonstration we are hosted on GCP and
we're sitting on top of a bigquery
database we're working off of a retail
data set and so we're goal with our
models and view files and our look ml is
to be able to support end user
experiences like the merchandising VP or
regional VP
logging in to look at performance most
of our time today is gonna be spent here
in this developed tab but what we'll do
is we'll start in the admin tab by
creating a database connection so once
that database connection is created the
develop tab is where we build our look
or semantic model or the look ml for
those of us that are developing and look
ml we're exposing those models to end
users via this explore tab and for those
end users whatever they're building in
this explore tab then populates the
browse tab which then also populates
these boards and folders for end users
now starting in the admin panel I want
to take you all to our database
connections and establish a database
connection and we'll open this in a new
tab now when you're establishing a
database connection you can go ahead and
add the new connection button up here at
the top for our demo we already have a
connection established with looker data
so I'm going to go ahead and edit this
connection so we can see how this is set
up so we have our look or data
connection the dialog we are connected
to as I mentioned is bigquery but if I
open up this panel you can see all the
different dialects a variety of the
different dialects that looker connects
to along the google front we've got
legacy standard Postgres sequel and also
cloud sequel and called spanner once
we've selected the dialect you can
select a project name and data set name
that you're pointing looker too but
let's say your use case calls for a
little bit more dynamicism you can also
use user attributes and looker to
dynamically set a value for a user or a
group if you're pointing them to
separate project names or data sets
now within Google many of you might use
OAuth and so looker does integrate with
OAuth and we can use OAuth or I am
integration we support service accounts
so that's another way that you can
support authentication and connection
settings within looker add your user
names and your passwords and then down
here at the bottom another interesting
feature here is that max billing
gigabytes so if you wanted to set a
maximum number of bytes billed
aloud on a single bigquery query you
could do that and then similar to those
hosts imports up there at the top if we
wanted to dynamically set this value for
users or groups we could now that the
connections been established what we
need to do is we need to create a look
ml project now the look of all projects
and looker
or essentially a house that contains all
of your model in your view files before
we move into that project what we want
to do is jump into development mode and
this allows me as a developer to start
editing or creating my own projects so
to walk you guys through the flow I'm
going to click on manage the Kamel
projects and I'll show you how to create
a new project up in the right-hand
corner will select new-look ml project
and what we'll do is we can give our
project a name a starting point in a
connection so we can name the project
whatever we'd like the starting point
really depends on how you would like to
begin building the logic for your
analysis so in many cases folks will
generate a model from a database schema
in this case looker scans the database
and brings back or automatically
generates the models in the view files
we can select generate from sequel clone
a public git repository which this demo
is based off of one of our blocks so if
you decided to point looker to one of
our public git repos that we have hosted
for a particular source or analytic
analysis we can point looker to that
repository and it will automatically
generate or pull those files for us as
well now in our case we already have a
project defined so in the development
tab I want to navigate you guys to the
retail demo and within the retail
dataset what you'll see here in the
upper left hand corner is we are version
controlled so when I jumped into
development mode I essentially put
myself into my own code branch we have
Luke imelda validation here on the left
side as well before you push changes to
production but the main components I
want to focus on here are models and
views so you'll see we have a model
folder I'm in a view folder that
contains a variety of different views
for looker a model file points to a
database connection so here we've
pointed it to our looker data connection
and within this connection what the file
tells looker is how to think about the
schema of that database and so in this
case we have our transactions table or
transaction view file right after an
explorer parameter now the file name
that comes after the Explorer parameter
populates the from clause and a sequel
query and so the way we read this is
from transactions join transaction light
items join customers join customer facts
and so on and so forth when we're
establishing join relationships we use
the relationship parameter and the
sequel parameter to help look or protect
against symmetric aggregates so once we
define these parameters looker will
automatically detect over-counting and
it will adjust to protect from from any
symmetric aggregates now in this piece
we have a transactions table we have a
transaction line items this is nested
data within bigquery and so looker works
seamlessly with nested data all we have
to do in the sequel parameter or what
looker will do when it detects a nested
field is it will do a left join
unnecessarily night UM's table so that
we can start to use this for analysis
and unpack that data now another
important thing here is our always
filter in look or you can use always
filter to apply a filter restriction on
this Explorer section so that when users
are running queries they're protected
against running large historical queries
but be that we are pointing them to a
big query partition so if we actually go
to the Explorer section and we type in
our retail our transaction detail
Explorer right here you'll notice at the
top we have a filter for transaction
date and it is required so no matter
what I pull if I cohere to the left-hand
side and I decide to pull channel name
that sequel parameter will always have a
where clause pointing us to either the
partition time or the partition in
bigquery
now going back to our model file if our
model is where we point to the database
connection and we'd explain to looker
the schema the view files are how we
defined the tables now you'll notice
when we spun up the project looker will
automatically create a list of views for
us let's say there are views that I
would like to add there's two different
ways that we can start to add additional
files I can go ahead and create another
model if I'd like to point to another
database connection or I can create
views from table or create views
outright if I create a view from table
what that workflow looks like as I'm
iterating in my project looker will
bring you to a schema viewer where I can
simply select a schema I can select a
table maybe I'm selecting my Zillow data
here and at the bottom I can bring these
files or create views which will create
a new view file here in my project now
for the view files in this demonstration
today we have a few base views and a few
examples of derived tables or derived
views in looker so if I open up my views
drop down a couple of the core tables
that we have here are things like our
transactions table our store dimension
table our customer dim our product dim
if I look at our base transactions table
you can see the view name and the sequel
table name which points us to that table
sitting in the database the schema table
name and every column coming from the
database is now its own dimension now
you'll notice underneath each dimension
we have a couple different parameters
I'm in this case we've got a type number
this is the primary key and in the
sequel parameter it's pointing looker to
table dot transaction ID now this table
is injecting that sequel table named
retail demo transaction detail dot
transaction ID now this injection
becomes very important when we are
deriving new fields
look ER so if we come down here to our
derive dimensions you'll notice a couple
of different examples one example is a
dimension group so we've got since first
customer transaction what we're doing is
we've derived a new field in this case
it's a trip mentioned group of type
duration and we've given looker a sequel
start in a sequel end date to derive the
months since our customer first
transacted now why this is significant
is instead of pointing to a table dot
column name a field that exists in the
database I'm pointing us to another
field in order to derive a new field and
so sequel is a declarative language but
it doesn't always lend itself well to
the benefits of object-oriented
programming and so this is an example
where look ml really brings in those
values of object-oriented programming in
the sense of reusability and
extensibility so when I continue to
scroll down here and I'm looking at my
measures you know number of transactions
number of customers I can start to pull
counts and sums and averages on
particular fields that are coming from
the looker data model customer ID and
store ID or we can become a little more
complex with our aggregations by
notating a measure of type number and
actually doing the the aggregation or
doing the calculation and the sequel
itself now to make it really rich for
end-users you'll notice on all of these
measures we have these drill detail
fields these drill details will specify
a list of fields that is pulled back
when a user clicks on that aggregation
and so you'll see drill details defined
up here so if you user defines or clicks
on one of those metrics or measures
lookers gonna uncover the date the store
name the product area of the product
name so that the user can see the row
level detail related to that metric now
if our base transaction table is an
example of a core table coming from our
database connection a couple of examples
of
tables and liquor are our customer facts
or our customer transaction sequence
table so if we look at the customer
facts table what you'll quickly notice
is we have the view name but instead of
the sequel table name we've invoked a
derived table and under the derived
table it allows you to drop in a simple
sequel statement or a complex sequel
statement so that you can start to
derive or prototype schema changes
what's powerful about this is you don't
need to physically copy the data on the
database side or create a fact table on
the database side in order for liquor to
leverage or for you to prototype what
type of analysis this would give you you
can simply create that analysis and
looker and if you'd like to speed it up
we can start to persist these pieces of
data so you'll notice here we've got
data grouped triggers um so this derived
table is governed by a caching policy
that's a daily caching policy and a
shortcut and looker if I hold down the
option key
I'll get this plus button I can click on
that data group trigger and looker will
navigate me to where that's been defined
you'll notice it took me back to my
retail block modeling file where our
data groups have been defined in this
case our daily data group is triggered
by a select current date and the
contingency here is a Max cash age why
this is really powerful is if we want to
sync liquor up with your data pipeline
let's say we want to sync liquor with
your ETL processes we can define a
sequel trigger that detects changes in
your ETL files so maybe when a new ETL
process is completed we can signify a
rebuild of that derived table or a
recache in of that table so going back
to the customer facts table you'll also
notice a few pieces here things like
partition keys and cluster keys now when
look are sitting on top of a database
bigquery or or otherwise it is enhancing
what
coming from the database so given that
we can optimize bigquery by utilizing
partition keys and cluster keys looker
inherently has parameters that we can
use to leverage or define these
partition keys and cluster keys for
folks that are defining direct tables
now for the derived table we can create
this derived table by instead of
creating a view from table creating a
view outright the other way we can do it
is we can use looker to generate the
direct table for us so a really powerful
workflow and looker is to use the
Explorer section to generate a sequel
query now for the end user it will
always look like a result set but for
the more technical developer that sequel
query is something that you can use for
your projects and models so let's say
this represented a derived table that I
would like to use for project I can open
and sequel on our deer in the bottom
right hand corner and looker will move
my query back to the sequel Runner
sequel runner can be navigated to here
in our development tab but once that
query is run and I'll just take a look
at the result set here I can go into the
upper right hand corner and I can get
derived table look ml so I can already
derive that table and create the view
file for myself you'll see that every
column coming from that view file are
coming from that sequel query is now
been its own measure in dimension and
all I need to do is add it back to my
project so you can use looker to
expedite the sequel writing process for
you even if you're writing a derived
table or a native derived table you can
use looker to help you generate that
sequel and generate that view file now
aside from the customer facts table we
also have examples of be qml being
utilized in looker our stock forecasting
tables and our customer clustering
tables are two examples here so if we
start with the stock forecasting table
you'll notice a little different flavor
of a derived table instead of
a sequel specific derive table we're
using something called a native derived
table and liquor why needed ripe tables
are powerful is as you'll notice they're
not dialect specific so look ml as a
modeling layer it is a sequel
translation layer the value there is
that with any point-and-click of an
end-user lucre is translating those
clicks into optimized sequel for
whatever database we're sitting on top
of so in the case of native derived
tables given that these are not dialect
specific it makes it really easy if I'm
going through you know a data warehouse
modernization project or I'm moving back
ends and using looker as the front end
to help me with that migration I can
simply swap out the connection name in
my model file and I can reuse these
derived tables I don't need to rewrite
them into a different dialect so the
soft forecasting shows a nice example of
that within the stock forecasting view
file and forgive me for my scrolling but
I have to scroll down to the bottom here
we'll be able to see examples of our B
qml model so with the be qml model here
we did feed in about 200 inputs just
from our transactions table and
ultimately what we're doing is we're
using B qml linear regression to
forecast sales by store by item and by
week and so if we get down here to the
regression you can see here that we're
using our sequel create statement on
this derived table to create or replace
the name of that derived table and using
linear regression here now they're
defined in our look ml model so if I
want to change our linear regression or
iterate on some of these B qml models we
can easily iterate on those models
validate them and test them on the front
end you also notice down here that we're
also doing some sort of prediction on
our stock forecasting as well now for
customer clustering
this is a really good example of using
clustering to create customer segments
so again we have our customer clustering
input up here at the top where we're
inputting a native derived table coming
from looker and then we can define the
clustering model here with k-means
clustering and we've defined the
clusters of four and so with those
clusters then on the front end we can
use our customers Explorer to start to
explore those those different customer
segments whether they are millenials Gen
Xers whether they're net new customers
and you'll see down here at the bottom
that we also have a customer clustering
prediction and so what this is doing is
this is out of the box with our block to
help cluster our customers into those
buckets whether there are Millennials
retirees or Gen Xers again this can be
used right out of the box with this
retail block or if you'd like to iterate
on this model or customize it in any way
shape or form you can now the last piece
I wanted to touch on before we moved
into the explore section was our public
data sets that we're working with so if
we look at our store weather table here
and looker listen is this is an example
where we're using the bigquery global
daily weather public data set to map a
retailer stores to the nearest weather
stations we want to get each stores
daily weather out of the box and so you
can see the bigquery of public data set
being leveraged here for all different
years and the mapping that's happening
on looker so I do like to describe the
look ml model and looker is kind of a
lightweight transformation layer so you
can see that some of these models are
very complex you can host a lot of
complex logic but more importantly I'm
able to leverage really any function or
functionality that is coming from
bigquery or GCP to make this really rich
for our end users now with all of those
pieces and I'll go ahead and stay logged
in
we want to navigate to the explores
right so all of the work we've done with
our store whether views all of our
transaction and our clustering what
we've done is we've gone into our model
file and we've defined different
explores transaction detail customer and
we have all of the joins defined and so
for myself as an end-user what makes
that what what's really easy to do is to
now move into the Explorer section and
build any analysis that I'd like so if
we go ahead into the Explorer section
I'm going to navigate back to our
transaction detail and I'm actually
going to jump out of development mode
and so now on my transaction detail
Explorer on the left hand side
everything that was joined are now
tables that I can point and click from
so if I look at our transactions table I
can see I can pivot filter or add some
sort of a custom measure if I'm a
developer I can move backwards into the
locum l this is really important that
lucre allows you to move seamlessly from
the front end to the back end the
architecture being simplified as it is
given that all of your metrics are
governed under one developed tab it's
very easy to understand how not only how
things are defined but up to to update
metrics and to update dimensions for
end-users to deliver the analysis that
they want now along with those
dimensions there are my dimension groups
with all of my type time and down here
at the bottom and orange are all of my
measures now we do have our access
filter up here at the top or our filter
for our partitions up here at the top
and so let's say I want to do a
year-over-year sample let's say I would
like to look at data for the past four
years
so I'd like to do a year over year for
the past four years I can go ahead and
add my month number into the analysis I
might want to look at my total sales
year-over-year and I will pivot that by
my year bucket and we can give that a
run now you might have noticed in the
upper right hand corner
as I'm querying liquor will tell you
whether it's pulling from cash or it
will tell you how large the results it
will predict the size of the query
before you run it now when it returns a
visualization I've got my visualization
along with the data table I can go ahead
and start to play with how this is
visualized so let's say I want to not
plot null values and I'd like to add an
outline to my year of a year analysis
again this is all being generated off of
that core model so there are all of
those time zone conversions the filters
that I've added in our sequel statement
for the end user it's a simplified
result set as soon as it's rendered I
can drill if I want to look at all 350
4k on this data point looker will also
automatically handle time hierarchies so
if I want to continue to drill down into
different time hierarchies here I can
but to support that data analysis
workflow if I want to then add this back
to my dashboard or save it as a report I
can I can also save and start to
schedule this out so we're talking about
integrated insights or data-driven work
clothes what I can do is I can set those
data here and workflows here in the
Explorer and start to push those out to
different users or groups or set those
workflows in motion that are going to be
most beneficial to me now if I go to
save this back to my dashboard I'll go
into my folder here and we can save it
back to our group overview that we
started on and I'm going to call this
your viewer sales now we can head back
to the group overview dashboard and this
is where the end users are going to come
to consume all of the stock forecasting
customer clustering the public data sets
that we've laced in to this demo but now
it's an easy to consume format it's
visual I can see my basket size if I'm a
VP of retail I can see the percent of
customers that are transacting from my
loyalty customers I can see
geographically where my stores are
located and if I want to dig into any
sort of top movers
I can look at my change by store and
chained by category and I can easily
start to take action on these so now if
I want to integrate with Google App
Engine and create a text or a call
function to contact that store manager
we can send a text quickly to that store
manager I can go ahead and grab the link
that would hit their inbox and when I
open that link I'll be taken to a store
deep-dive that's already been updated
for my Los Angeles store and so I can
easily start to take a look at why the
store might be underperforming and then
look at different examples of that work
we did on the back end and how it's
displaying on the front end so if we're
looking at our peer store comparison I
can see how I'm doing versus my peer
stores I can look at the weather trends
to see if my transactions decreasing has
anything to do with the weather and then
when we get down to stock forecasting
here I can easily see how much of a
product I have in stock versus what's
forecasted and what the stock difference
might be and then if I need to take
action on any of these pieces I can go
ahead and explore from here and move
backwards into the rapport building
interface or I can start to alert when
my stock difference in this case might
be greater than or equal to a particular
value and of course this is just the bi
and analytics workflow so if we want to
get more advanced certainly this could
become an iframe that I then embed into
a custom application any of these points
become API endpoints or query and
endpoints that I can pull in to a custom
application or a custom workflow but
that's the end of my technical deep dive
on looker I hope that it was informative
and thanks so much for joining